echo  enemy has f  b locked out  losing c  taking delta  body drop  securing delta  [Music]  [Music]  losing charlie  [Music]  [Music]  we lost charlie  taking foxtrot  [Music]  uh  charlie  enemy took alpha  secure  [Music]  securing  lethality  grenade  [Music]  multiple hostile spy planes today  charlie secure  what's your target id  [Music]  established over here  [Music]  [Music]  hustle artillery targeting active  losing  multiple enemies  [Music]  target mark  [Music]  hostile spy plane established overhead  wrong stun  [Music]  road  securing delta  [Music]  taking delta  security  [Music]  detected in your aorta  [Music]  [Music]  hustle artillery targeting active  net call incoming artillery  spy plane neutralized  losing c  [Music]  enemies  attack helicopter inbound  multiple hostels  [Music]  [Music]  withdrawal withdrawal the reds have got  us beat  anyone want to quit  do you think so  hostile removed  [Music]  uh